[Musique]
savoir quelle nature
je n'ai juste pas ces zones est piloté
saliba c'est les bassins goûte un peu
comme le pop corn l'assaisonnement
[Musique]
la réaction qu'on abat ce moment c'est
celle là ouache des insectes les gens ne
veulent pas vraiment manger même s'ils
sont consommés par plus de 2 milliards
d'humains sur la planète les insectes
suscite plus souvent qu'autrement peur
et dégoût en occident depuis la
publication d'un rapport de la fao en
2013 et beaucoup de gens qui ont
commencé à regarder les insectes d'un
nouvel erp quelque peu d'entreprises
d'avoir un droit puisqu'ils sont lancés
dans les rois de la consommation
d'insectes et on a vu ça aussi aux états
unis finalement ici au canada dry a
trait à l'eau et les insectes u7 russe à
l'épaule avant texto vraiment porté en
crawl de l'insulteur économique
écologique riche en protéines et
minéraux l'organisation des nations
unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture la fao voit les insectes
comme une solution pour améliorer la
sécurité alimentaire alors que la
population de la planète ne cesse
d'augmenter et que les ressources elles
s'amenuisent se battrait pour une pluie
pour samuel richard jonathan jeudi les
propriétaires d'un sextuor le déclic
s'est fait alors qu'ils étudiaient en
biologie à l'université du québec à
trois rivières
nous on est vraiment des tripeux
d'insectes qui ont un ami qui a
travaillé avec georges brossard pour
l'insectarium moi c'était comme un rêve
d'enfant de rencontrer georges en vrai
plus pouvoir lui parler puisse vraiment
avoir une grande porte en nous disant
regardez les gars je veux donner des
trucs
puis ç'a valu de l'or pour nous pour le
projet c'est que ce soir
en mode essai erreur le soir et les fins
de semaine ils ont ensuite développé et
commercialisé de la farine d'insectes et
des télés brion déshydraté antilles mais
le plus gros défi demeure celui de
changer les mentalités
on observe certainement un plus grand
intérêt pour goûter mais pas
nécessairement pour en avoir en tendance
est à voir comme un produit qui est
particulièrement commun c'est difficile
d'avoir de nouveaux clients mais les
gens qui essayent la farine d'un sec la
majorité tombe en amour avec ce produit
le drame au plus au rac ici que bien
installé au domaine de la korité du en
mauricie insectivores est maintenant
prêt à élargir ses horizons en
développant de nouveaux produits à base
d'insectes comestibles pour changer le
monde une personne à la foule
il si amélie desmarais radio canada
trois rivières